[Musique]
bon je dois la réunion bon jeu le monde
comment il est alors aujourd'hui on est
on est à saint pierre la rivière d'abord
c'est par là on va monter pas là à les
voir olivier qui fabrique ses pattes
alors maraï par la patte chaise non pas
là pas de cochon non plus mais non pas
la patte de table des pattes de pasta
recommandé d'installer des bonnes pâtes
pour manger alors moi je vous propose
quelque chose c'est de me suivre et
devenir très vite
allez on y va bon olivier bonjour
comment construit les cent vingt mille
personnes
bienvenue chez moi voilà c'est
exactement ça me dit moi chez toi c'est
quoi
enfin bref d'être atteint on fabrique
que des patrons on essaie de les biens
et fabriqué mais on fabrique que ça
des pâtes des pâtes des pâtes fraîches
des pâtes fraîches 100% italienne mais
surtout 100% fabrique à la réunion
d'accord ben écoute moi j'aimerais que
tu nous montre un petit peu tout ça est
passé partie 1
on fait comme ça allait on fait comme ça
m'a coûté ma wiimote et les verts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aulas yeux
tu fabriques de pâtes des 10 mois sont
un peu plus le pourquoi le comment et
avec quoi qualité la réunion etc etc
moi ça m'intéresse pas ok donc bon déjà
là vous êtes donc ici c'est notre
entreprise l'entreprise en fait elle a
deux domaines d'activités elle un
premier domaine d'activité qui est la
production et la distribution pas trash
et alimentaires ce qu est devenu donc
voir aujourd'hui est la deuxième
activité c'est une petite activité de
de restauration ici dans leurs notes bar
à pâtes et donc on a choisi de
s'orienter sur la fabrication de pâte
parce que parce que moi il ya une chose
maintenant tout le monde en est persuadé
c'est que les pâtes fraîches n'est pas
très chaud bien évidemment les pâtes
fraîches qui sont faites vraiment d'une
façon tout à fait traditionnelle ça
reste ça reste un produit qui est sain
ça reste un produit qui est qui en
termes de calories
bon maintenant tout le monde sait que
c'est pas une bombe calorique et cetera
donc on est sur un produit on est sur un
produit d'exception et on est sur un
produit 100 puisque ici c'est fabriqué
ici
dis moi même bien sûr je suppose que le
goût parce que le goût marmaille ça
compte
c'est totalement différent aussi alors
le goût il est complètement différent
parce qu'on est sûr on est sur un
produit qui vaquent évacuèrent très vite
on assure on est sur une cuisson 2 à peu
près entre une minute trente une minute
ça permet d'avoir des départs qui vont
être cuisson alda tout le monde connaît
un petit peu le terme al dente
dis moi combien patty a en gros 1
combien de variétés de pâtes et à
combien on peut faire c'est raté alors
je juge très honnêtement je ne sais pas
combien il existe deux sortes de grâce
vous mais nous déjà ici dans le
au sein de l'entreprise on peut on peut
fabriquer environ
plus d'une trentaine de sortes de pâtes
différente parce qu'en fait on va jouer
sur deux on a différents bull on le
verra tout à l'heure quand on allait en
salle de préparation
ils font donc on a donc on peut
travailler sur différentes sans sur des
pattes courtes sur des pattes longue et
puis après on peut travailler avec des
pattes qui vont être au basilic des
pâtes qui vont être encre de seiche des
pâtes qui vont être avec des épinards où
il met des brèdes on peut mettre du
curcuma tout et tout est possible tout
est il ya zéro limite dans le temps la
préparation des plats
[Musique]
et donc les fameuses pâtes à l'en avant
tout donc il ya alors là on jouait alors
la ici de relents en vitrine on s'est un
petit peu de là on a des feuilles de
lasagne défaite voilà donc en fait voilà
la différence elle est ce qu'on peut
trouver dans le sais j'en sais que c'est
tout ici on a une forme une forme simple
cd ce qu'on appelle des trenchs et on a
une production qui est quotidienne tout
les patrons toutes les pâtes qu'on
distribue où toutes les pâtes qu'on
consomme ici dans le restaurant c'est
des pâtes qui sont faites du jour donc
on résume les pattes ça se passe ici
c'est fait ici juste derrière on va les
voir tout à l'heure les sauces je dis ça
c'est un peu mou
les sas fabriqués ici avec les légumes
avec des produits des produits locaux
les produits locaux de saison exactement
et cetera par donc dcr fraises attaque
tacle
ça dépendra de la saison bien sûr ben
moi j'appelle ça comme moi j'appelle ça
du du passé moi je pense qu'il n'en a
pas encore assez là on va le faire un
petit tour d il ya qu à voir comment ça
se passe je pense un oui oui on y va un
monde humain parfait
[Musique]
alors olivier le laboratoire je t'en
supplie j'ai de suite
donc déjà donc varenquas marine kaki et
marica qui est la préparatrice ici à la
casa pathé qui est particulièrement
chargé de toute la production toute la
production de pâtes mais également tous
les excellents dessert que tu as lu en
vitrine et toutes les sauces et c'est
elle qui fait c'est le sait la colonne
vertébrale de l'entreprise vend de la
viande n'a fait sans elle rien n'est
possible
[Musique]
donc en fait ici c'est tout simple on
appelle mari s'il ya une capacité de 5
lots donc on pèse
varin qui apaise la paix de la semoule
et mais la semoule ici donc la semoule
en fait on dit semoule parce que c'est
vraiment de la small c'est pas de là
c'est pas du tout là c'est pas du tout
de la farine quoi c'est vraiment de la
seconde bien voilà on prend la semoule
en place de la semoule
on met la semoule dans le pétrin mais
ensuite on pèse on pèse les donc en fait
les oeufs c'est sa place et un nombre
d'heures c'est un nombre d'oeuvres bien
spécifique pour un clou de ce multi d'un
petit secrétaire ça c'est mon petit
secret et si j'ai pas on peut échanger
le secret jamais 6 me par exemple je
sais pas moi j'ai des aimants secrets et
des grosses qui peut changer ta vie
sérieusement donc moi je propose tu me
donnes ton secret je te redonne sac
moment ce créneau ça marche pas ça
marchera pas non il est pas on va
compléter avec deux loups l'essai c'est
vraiment ce parti qui est très
spécifique
surtout ici à la réunion par exemple
aujourd'hui il pleut bon c'est beaucoup
plus humide
si on veut avoir si on veut avoir une
qualité de pâte qui est tout le temps la
même banque là tu peux toucher c'est
très souple à la wii donc si on veut
avoir une qualité de pâte qui est
toujours là même qu'ils soient pas trop
chargés en eau etc etc
eh ben on est obligé de s'adapter à
l'hygrométrie à l'hygrométrie de
du jour de fabrication pour avoir pour
avoir une pâte qui soit qu'ils soient
vraiment vraiment impeccable parce que
de toute façon si c'est trop sec ou si
c'est trop humide ça sortira mal et donc
ça c'est le travail de ce travail de
varen car il va qui va qui va gérer
qu'il va gérer ces pourcentage
d'humidité en fonction d'eux en fonction
de l'hygrométrie ambiante
[Musique]
donc the wall of life ou au c'est tout
si on ne met que cela dans nos patrons
mais pas d'agent de texture on met pas
de colorants on met pas de stabilisants
ans nommé à rien d'autre
[Musique]
à
ça ce sont des tags étaient aux épinards
voilà on regarde couleurs et en formes
simples et rennes grimpe de jeunes
traînent et ça c'est des packs nature et
pour le coup tu rajoutes les épinards ou
avant on n'a pas le temps là dans la
pâte dans la préparation lors de la
préparation on rajoute les épinards donc
ces orages ou c'est dans le liquide dans
le mélange oeuf dans le mélange oeuf et
au on va rajouter on va rajouter les
ingrédients pour pour tâter la base ou
pour ajouter du goût donc ça peut être
ça peut être comme je disais tout à
l'heure ça peut être mal séché ça peut
des champignons ça peut être des
épinards sap et du basilic
ça peut être des brèdes sept poètes de
la roquette ça peut être du citron tout
ce qu'on veut
pas cette fois
pleurer
c'est toi
[Musique]
manger les parts ça me
un choc quatre pattes là
olivier moi je sais bien fait les caries
mais les pattes je ne sais pas les faire
dis moi tout s'il te plaît alors rien de
plus simple les franchement c'est
beaucoup plus facile de faire des pâtes
que décarie quel est donc votre route
donc là normalement mono voilà mon noël
bouhail a pas de c'est du gros bouillons
ah oui oui là c'est très important
d'avoir vraiment un gros gros gros gros
gros bouillons en à peu près 160 g ici
de pâte crue on a fait des fusili nature
et des fusées initial encre de seiche
qui va nous donner un petit goût déjà
qu'il va avoir une belle couleur tu vas
voir quand ça dans la tête c'est très
joli et surtout ça rajoute un petit bout
iodé et ça va être très sympa
et donc voilà c'est parti et la maman on
n'a plus qu'à patienter pendant une
minute trente y'a pas de problème de jeu
colle je colle pas je m'achète tout ça
colle pas d'accord voilà ça colle pas tu
as vu dans l'eau j'ai pas mis d'huile
il n'y a pas de pas de tout ça rien
juste de l'eau et du sel
on est toujours un petit peu dans ce
truc qu'on n'ajoute rien
alors attention croche pas non je suis
pas une si coppens un petit peu plus
haut
donc ça c'est de la tomate séchée le
pesto traditionnel basilic et pour la
fin on va mettre un petit peu de
parmesan quand même tous
ce projet
je peux plus
en juillet
dis-moi comment tu es arrivé justement à
fabrication patch dans la région de nice
nos habitudes alimentaires à nous les
gens du sud les vents du sud-est de la
france est bien scellé patricia la
réunion céleri et nous c'est les pattes
de là est venue l'idée de
de monter cette petite entreprise et
voilà comment la halle aventure a
commencé
ça fait combien de temps en fait que tu
aimes que tu aimes ce petit restaurant
fonctionne et qui on est on est là
maintenant dans la huitième année
d'activité dix mois dans ton petit
atelier d ailleurs combien de kilos de
pâques tu préfères par jour
on va dire en théorie c'est à peu près
12 kg de pâte à l'heure d'abord parce
que bon bah ça scellier scellier a la
capacité de la machine
et puis voilà comme tu as pu le voir
tout se fait à la main etc dont on n'a
pas une capacité de production qui est
qui et non en ce qui concerne nous
maintenant du point de vue très pratique
on tourne à peu près en moyenne sur
l'année on a à peu près à 500 600 kg de
pâtes par ben d'accord lantus est
habituellement j'ai dit devant les
spectateurs
au revoir olivier à la prochaine et
c'est là je veux pas le faire là je
crois que vais rester encore un peu avec
toi si j'ai un bon plat de pâtes à finir
je vais de dévorer tout ça voila voila
je le ventre bien plein après un bon
plat de pâtes
alors pour digérer on a décidé de
s'arrêter sur le crois de saint-pierre
respirer l'air marin
comment ça fait du bien alors je vous
dis tout simplement aurevoir à la
prochaine fois et surtout du tout son
psy de l'auberge sérieux on n'est pas
sorti de l'auberge du tout parce qu'avec
les pattes avec tout ça commence au bout
oulala
[Musique]